In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 28th, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostles
and Deacons, Prochorus, Nicanor, Timon and Parmenas.
These saints were disciples of the Twelve Apostles and were included in the number of the 70.
As Saint Luke reports in the Acts of the Apostles, they were men of good repute and filled with
the Spirit of Wisdom and were chosen to be Deacons with Saint Stephen in order to assure
the material service of the Apostolic community.
When they seized to serve the widows and the poor of Jerusalem, Prochorus left to preach
the good news, putting himself at the service of Saint John the theologian, the beloved disciple.
It was to him that Saint John dictated his gospel, epistles, and the revelation, and together
they suffered all kinds of trials and tribulations for the name of Christ.
After Saint John had gone to heaven, Prochorus became, it is said, Bishop of Nicomedia.
He undertook to set a right the behavior of its inhabitants who were slaves of their passions.
With perseverance and gentleness, he taught them not to submit the superior to the inferior,
the Spirit to the body, but to govern the body through use of a right reason and a soul
purified through repentance.
It was in the course of this task that the blessed Saint ended his life and went to join
Saint John in the assembly of the first born.
Saint Nicomedia gave his soul into God's hands on the same day that his companion and fellow
deacon Stephen was stoned to death by the Jews.
It was fitting that these two blessed saints, united by their love of Christ, should find
rest on the same day.
Saint Padminas served the apostles all his life, and thus became pleasing to Christ and his
saints.
He gave his soul into God's hands after an illness, and was buried by the apostles.
Saint Dimon also served the needs of the apostles in the community of Saint Stephen, and was
later consecrated Bishop of Bostra in Arabia.
He fought a superhuman battle there in order to preach the good news and brought a great
number of pagans to the faith.
Martin Barbarians, furious at his success, seized him, beat him, and put him to death by fire.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.